.
>> Shannon: THE BORDER CRISIS IS
NOW FACING A HOUSING CRISIS, FOR
THE THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS TRYING
TO GET INTO THE U.S. AND THE
HUNDREDS OFF LAW ENFORCEMENT
WORKERS WHO HAVE NOWHERE TO PUT
THEM.
RESPOND DID HE WANT BILL MELUGIN
REPORTS TONIGHT FROM LA JOYA,
TEXAS.
>> THE FOX FLIGHT TEAM OVER
McALLEN, TEXAS EARLY WEDNESDAY
MORNING WHERE WE HAVE LEARNED
OVERNIGHT THE CITY BEGAN
CONSTRUCTING THESE EMERGENCY
SHELTERS MEANT TO HOUSE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS RELEASED FROM BORDER
PATROL CUSTODY.
BY AFTERNOON, MIGRANTS HAD
ALREADY STARTED ARRIVING.
THE CITY SAYS THEY HAVE TO BUILD
THIS COMPOUND TO HELP HOUSE AN
OVERWHELMING AMOUNT OF MIGRANTS
LEFT STRANDED IN McALLEN AFTER
RELEASED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THE CITY WRITING IN A STATEMENT
THEY INTEND TO, QUOTE, DEMAND
RELIEF FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THE ALARMING
NUMBER OF IMMIGRANTS BEING
RELEASED INTO THE CITY OF
McALLEN AND THAT AS THESE
IMMIGRANTS ARE RELEASED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES NOT TEST
THEM FOR COVID-19.
BACK ON MONDAY, WE WERE IN
DOWNTOWN McALLEN AS WE WATCHED
BORDER PATROL DROP OFF BUS LOADS
OF MIGRANTS EVERY 30 MINUTES
RELEASING THEM FROM THEIR
CUSTODY TO A CATHOLIC CHARITY
THAT NO LONGER HAS THE CAPACITY
TO TAKE IN SO MANY PEOPLE.
THE CITY OF McALLEN SAYS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS RELEASED
OVER 7,000 COVID POSITIVE
MIGRANTS INTO THEIR CITY SINCE
FEBRUARY.
INCLUDING MORE THAN 1500 IN JUST
THE LAST WEEK ALONE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS NOW
REPORTEDLY PLANNING TO BEGIN
OFFERING COVID-19 VACCINES TO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN FEDERAL
CUSTODY.
NOW WITH THESE EMERGENCY
SHELTERS GOING UP TO TRY TO HELP
CONTAIN THE CRISIS, LOCALS WE
TALKED TO AREN'T HAPPY IT WAS
DONE OVERNIGHT WITH NO WARNING.
>> WE ARE INUNDATED WE KNOW THAT
TRUTHFULLY I BELIEVE THERE IS
NOT ENOUGH PLANES OR BUSES TO
GET ALL THESE PEOPLE OUT OF
HERE.
AGAIN, THERE PROBABLY COULD HAVE
BEEN A BETTER LOCATION THAN
STICKING IT RIGHT SMACK IN THE
MIDDLE OF McALLEN.
>> IT'S JUST REALLY SCARY
BECAUSE JUST RIGHT ACROSS THE
STREET FROM THIS HOLDING
FACILITY YOU SEE HOMES WHERE
PEOPLE LIVE.
>> AND SHANNON, WE GOT SOME LATE
BREAKING NEWS WE WOULD LIKE TO
REPORT TO YOU.
JUST GOT A FEW TEXTS FROM A
CONTACT TEXAS DPS A HORRIBLE
VEHICLE CRASH IN BROOKS COUNTY
SOUTH OF THE BORDER PATROL
STATION ABOUT AN HOUR SOUTH OF
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
WHAT WE ARE TOLD IS THERE WAS A
VAN DRIVING 24 PEOPLE IN IT.
ALL OF THEM SUSPECTED TO BE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THAT DRIVER VEERED OFF THE ROAD,
CRASHED INTO A UTILITY POLE,
THERE IS 11 CONFIRMED DEAD
PEOPLE RIGHT NOW INCLUDING THE
DRIVER, 13 HURT.
THEY ARE STILL INVESTIGATING
THIS THEY ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
IDENTIFYING THE DEAD AND
NOTIFYING THE MEXICAN CONSULATE
BUT A HORRIBLE, HORRIBLE CRASH.
I'M TOLD THERE WAS NOT A PURSUIT
HERE.
THESE WERE JUST MIGRANTS BEING
TRANSPORTED UNCLEAR IF IT WAS A
HUMAN SMUG GLERKS 11 DEAD RIGHT
NOW HORRIBLY TRAGI